on est le 9 septembre il est 16h
Jean-Baptiste termine sa promenade
quotidienne dans le parc de la Villette
à Paris se dirige vers chez vous où ils
viennent parti du mois
et se doute pas qu'il est suivi non
il ne sait pas il ne sait pas il va
rentrer dans l'immeuble il va rentrer
dans mon immeuble aussi terrasse du parc
et sur la carambar de surveillance on
voit un individu qui le suit à 15 mètres
et qu'il ouvre afin de ne pas de se
faire voir de mon père mon père à 92 ans
il n'aurait pas vu de toute façon bien
sûr il rentre dans le patio
et là
l'individu le suit mon père se dirige
sur les escaliers dans mon rôle je suis
à l'étage
d'y mettre
et là au moment où il va grimper les
escaliers il reçoit un gros coup violent
à l'arrière du crâne et là je pense
qu'il a une grosse commotion cérébrale
il ne peut pas m'appeler on peut pas
m'appeler mais normalement il aurait dû
m'appeler je suis son référent je suis
la personne qui lui donne confiance et
s'il m'avait appelé j'aurais été à son
secours et depuis je ressasse cet
événement au quotidien
c'est incroyable
il a reçu des coups extrêmement violents
mais il a reçu un coup mais mon père
était un ancien gendarme et
malheureusement il n'a pas voulu donner
son argent et il a commencé à se battre
avec l'individu
et il a 92 ans l'individu par le coup et
il faut savoir que mon père n'avait plus
de force pour tourner ne serait-ce que
la clé de mon appartement c'était
compliqué mais là avec l'adrénaline et
la réussite serrer très fort et et
l'individu qui a 25 ans qui est un homme
non pas une femme oui c'est il faut bien
le justement oui c'est vrai parce que
c'est Gilles pour appeler
l'agresseur c'est un homme oui c'est un
homme avec alors on va le directe des
guillemets mais avec une attitude
féminine ce qui a d'ailleurs ce qui
aurait pu dérouter les enquêteurs mais
grâce aux caméras de vidéosurveillance
cette personne a été
identifiée et a pu être retrouvé bien
plus tard une semaine après par 450
policiers qui ont tout fait pour traquer
cette personne qu'ils l'ont retrouvé et
puis elle est aujourd'hui incarcérée en
détention heureusement et cette personne
heureusement c'est pas tout à fait ça
les 450 personnes c'est Nunez qui se
déplace le préfet de Paris lorsqu'il
fait une descente d'accord mais il faut
de comprendre que si on se déplace si le
préfet de Paris se déplace avec 450
personnes c'est que l'endroit est
terriblement dangereux exactement c'est
la bague qui a qui a interpellé avant
moi l'individu
je suis content que la BAC est fait son
travail et je suis content que cette
personne se retrouve en détention à
Fleury pour un bon moment
l'agresseur utilisait une sorte de
matraque c'est ça alors mon père a
employé un terme qui vient de du
pâturage qui est relayé relayée à mon
sens c'est se faire battre avec quelque
chose ça vient du monde paysan je ne
connais pas vraiment la terminaison mais
je crois lui il pense que c'est une
matraque souple dans lequel il y avait
un une bille de plomb
alors et alors quand il s'est battu avec
son son dirigés sur le patio
et là mon père s'aperçoit il croit que
c'est une femme et croyant c'est une
femme et la relâché son étreinte et là
l'enfer c'est déchaîné sur lui
et
là il a été projeté au sol et latte
en tous les sens et là il y a son bassin
son bassin vous voyez la tête du fémur
elle rentre dans le bassin et là il y a
deux fractures dont une qui est restée
ouverte pendant 3-4 jours ce sont pas
vraiment aperçus tout de suite que il
perdait énormément d'hémoglobine et
si vous voulez un être humain comme vous
et moi avons un taux de 16 de boglobine
un homme personne de 92 ans c'est plutôt
8 10 et lui il en avait plus 4 et donc
il a été dans entre la ville à mort
pendant deux trois jours il a été
supplémenté ensemble le service de
réanimation lui a redonné vie
et ensuite il a été transféré à
Lariboisière dans un service de gérer
Jérôme vous avez dit que vous ressassiez
cette agression puis des jours et des
jours à quel moment vous apprenez ce qui
vient de se passer
à peu près 7 à 8 minutes après
l'agression le gardien de mon immeuble
m'appelle mon peuple votre père a été
agressé je descends en catastrophe et là
je vois mon père je suis très en colère
parce que c'est quoi votre réaction au
départ vous dites je vais je suis très
en colère vis-à-vis de lui c'est triste
à dire oui parce que
je sentais qui allait se passer quelque
chose vous lui disiez d'aller arrêter de
sortir tout seul comme ça là je lui
avais dit écoute papa il pleut ne prend
pas ton parapluie il prend ta canne ce
serait mieux ne sors pas le climat n'est
pas bon j'ai essayé de l'intervenir mais
c'est un homme qui a toujours décidé
décider de tout et surtout de sa vie et
c'est dingue parce que je vous dis
quelque chose c'est dingue quand même
d'en venir à être et je comprends vous
êtes énervé parce que vous êtes j'aurais
pas dû les sortir mais d'être énervé de
ne pas se sentir autant en sécurité
c'est à dire que une personne de 92 ans
peut pas sortir de chez elle elle allait
faire un tour
tranquillement sans se faire agresser
c'est incroyable de dire ça de dire
parce que c'est c'est c'est vous aurez
vous en voulez bien entendu à
l'agresseur mais c'est vrai que vous
dites j'aurais pas dû le laisser sortir
oui je m'en veux mais j'en veux surtout
aux autorités pourquoi
vous savez ça fait 4 ans que le climat à
la porte de la Villette
se détériore dès l'avenue des 4000
migrants ça a pesé sur les consciences
ça a pesé sur
notre état d'esprit
à partir de ce moment-là la cohésion
sociale s'est détériorée et toujours
habiter là-bas j'ai toujours habitué de
papa aussi non mon père
là c'était dans le dernier mois d'accord
parce que
c'était un peu plus faible mais sinon il
venait une semaine sur deux lorsque j'ai
les enfants il vient et là il y a un
rebond qui se fait chez lui et vous
allez les contents de repartir après
chez nous et vous vous disiez chaque
jour le climat le pouvoir sortir comme
ça il va il va se passer quelque chose
ouais c'était une évidence implacable
j'étais obligé que ça allait arriver
mais il faut savoir que mon père c'est
une plainte par Mimile
c'est vous voyez la liste donc
commissariat du 19e c'est c'est pas 1000
plaintes c'est 10000 plaintes
c'est et puis vous avez la liste des
agresseurs et c'est systématiquement
dans cette zone
alors
vous avez évidemment déposé plainte on
découvre que le toxicoman résidait au
camp de toxicoman du scarceval du square
forceval des centaines de riverains se
mobilisent depuis des mois pour
l'évacuation du campement c'est ce que
vous nous disiez
je crois que pour faire évoluer les
choses il faut transposer le square dans
les jardins de l'Elysée
vous transposez le square dans les
jardins de l'Élysée et le problème sera
très vite résolu pour que les pour que
les autorités voient ce qui se passe
là-bas au quotidien nous Brigitte il va
falloir qu'elle enlève ses talons
franchement ouais l'hôtel de ville aussi
Monsieur Madame Hidalgo
en effet
n'a pas donné son véto elle aurait pu
s'opposer à Darmanin elle ne l'a pas
fait
je ne sais pas quelles ont été les
pressions
mais voilà le maire du 19e bien il est
sous la tutelle d'Hidalgo il a fait ce
qu'il a peut-être pu inalgo le maire de
Paris
aujourd'hui donc vous en voulez beaucoup
plus aux autorités qu'à l'agresseur en
fait
non j'en veux beaucoup à l'agresseur
vous autorités
je vous vois je savais que je
je me dis qu'est-ce qui serait passé si
vous aviez croiser l'agresseur quelques
minutes après
j'aurais fait exactement ce qu'aurait
fait mon père il y a 5 ans je lui aurais
tordu le coup
et je serai sorti avec les pinces
voilà ce que j'aurais fait faites quoi
dans la vie
je suis commerçant en immobilier
d'accord
et là vous vous êtes dit un moment où
vous êtes bien au moment où je vais me
faire justice moi-même
vous avez essayé de retrouver
l'agresseur
ah oui
c'est compliqué la réponse
les enfants regardent bien sûr non mais
c'est parce que c'est parce qu'il faut
faire et c'est vous avez dit puisque
tout à l'heure vous avez dit la BAC a
fait son travail il a trouvé avant moi
j'étais pas sûr du signalement donc on
était pas sûr
j'ai préféré laisser les autorités faire
est-ce que vous avez bien fait j'ai bien
fait j'ai bien fait j'ai des enfants il
faut bien sûr vous avez bien fait
aujourd'hui vous avez toujours
connu des gens qui sont allés c'est pas
une partie de plaisir et il va prendre
très cher
j'ai envie qu'ils prennent vous avez
envie qu'ils prennent très cher mais
bien sûr mais c'est ce qui va se passer
il va subir
mille fois ce qu'il a fait subir à mon
père
oui j'ai
très compliqué c'est vrai que moi
j'entends parfaitement que ce que vous
dites monsieur mais non mais tu m'as pas
dire
c'est que la police a fait son travail
et la personne ce que je trouve très
bien c'est que la justice attend pour
mettre en cause cette personne justement
de savoir ce qui va survenir pour votre
papa et que la la moi la condamnation
sera très très forte mais ça moi je vais
vous dire après je vous donne mon avis
aujourd'hui
donc il faut qu'il y ait l'état de du
père de Jérôme se dégrade pour que la
personne
est prennent cher moi les mecs je suis
désolé
c'est l'acte qu'il faut juger je suis
pas je veux mon avis moi je suis
personne 97 que l'acte va être qualifié
du fait il y a une utilisation d'une
arme bien sûr et au lieu de passer au
pénal il va passer aux assises
si c'est prouvé mais mon père n'est pas
un menteur mais non
votre père est dans quel état
aujourd'hui bien voilà il a perdu 10
kilos
il faisait 55 kg il en fait que 45
en 20 jours il faut qu'il reste
immobilisé encore 20 jours
si dans 20 jours il fait 35 il sort de
bukenval
et vous connaissez la finalité c'est
très très compliqué les médecins disent
quoi
espérance de vie à 6 mois annule
impossibilité de remarcher
moi j'ai espoir encore c'est quelqu'un
qui a une vie très compliquée très
difficile et qui peut avoir le ressort
notamment avec l'aide de mes
petits-enfants de mes enfants
on va voir j'espère mais aujourd'hui les
médecins sont pessimistes
cette photo date de 15 jours
c'est fortement dégradé déjà là on voit
qu'il est fortement à maigri
ça sent encore dégradé il faut savoir
faut savoir quand même mon père était
totalement autonome il jouait aux boules
encore avec ses petits enfants ramasser
ses boules il joue aux échecs tous les
jours aux dames
c'était quelqu'un qui avait la vie
ancrée en lui là
hyper pied surtout quand je vais le voir
parce que il sent ma détresse et mon
désespoir et
il reprend vite quand mes enfants
viennent le voir et là il y a peut-être
une lueur on sait jamais si il arrive à
continuer à s'alimenter un peu plus à
boire de façon plus régulière un miracle
il y a déjà eu un miracle peut-être un
second on verra bien est-ce que vous
savez si l'agresseur à
une des regrets à parler à la police et
indiquer regretter son geste ou si c'est
rendu compte de ce qu'il avait fait ou
bien pas du tout
c'est quelqu'un de conscient il a tout
de suite avoué à l'interrogatoire
je vais pas en dire plus parce que je
peux pas dévoiler mais oui oui c'est des
faits qui ont déjà été produit et
reproduits
voilà c'est tout ce que je peux dire
cette personne a déjà vu
oui oui c'est pas la première fois donc
oui
et il était déjà il était il a déjà été
en prison je ne sais pas en tout cas
récidive sur récidive et il était dehors
vous êtes venu nous voir ce soir
qu'est-ce que vous auriez envie de faire
passer comme message
et bien il faut absolument que
que l'on prenne en compte notre
situation afin de sortir de cette
ornière il faut savoir que
vous connaissez tous la Cour des
Miracles le cimetière des Innocents ou
pour qui sonne le glas voilà on est dans
l'enfer et cet enfer faut que ça cesse
faut vraiment que ça cesse et que un
quartier dans Paris voilà si vous nous
regardez port de La Villette et pour
vous là-bas c'est l'enfer
oui mais ça n'a pas été comme ça
non je pensais que les autorités
allaient réguler elles ont toujours
régulé la Villette ça a toujours été ça
mais dans un niveau bien moins moindre
il y a 156 nationalités qui vivaient en
harmonie plus ou moins mais tout se
régler dans les trois mois et la santé
que ça allait se passer comme ça
et là c'est devenu
le papa de Jérôme comme vous l'avez vu
comme à 10 Jérôme il est dans un état
très très sérieux
c'est dramatique et votre témoignage ce
soir Jérôme j'espère qu'il va faire
bouger les choses parce que voilà oui
merci de m'avoir
invités
c'est un cercle tout autour du square et
ça comprend des dizaines de milliers de
gens et ça s'étend sur Paris sur trois
quatre stations de métro si votre papa
s'en sort
on espère qu'il va s'en sortir
je le souhaite vous allez
vous allez vous essayer de faire
reprendre une vie normale essayer de
vous y croyez ou pas
s'il passe les caps des 20 jours j'ai
peut-être une possibilité de le
remobiliser et de lui faire retrouver
une minimum de d'autonomie voilà les
jours critiques c'est les 20 prochains
jours
mon ex-femme est médecin elle me cache
pas
son inquiétude son inquiétude
elle est très très pessimiste aussi et
c'est pourtant quelqu'un de très je
trouve très calme Jérôme mais vraiment
votre témoignage
il nous touche encore plus par votre
calme et votre analyse de la situation
on espère tous bien sûr que votre papa
va aller mieux on espère tous que les
choses vont bouger là-bas parce que il
va y avoir d'autres drames ça bougera
c'est pour ça que Jérôme était là
aujourd'hui merci jérôme est venu nous
voir merci